[Música]
bueno
en mi vida para mí siempre ha sido de
verdad muy valioso empezar por él porque
así que por eso hoy quiero empezar
porque si lo gana plástica y hablándote
dentro de la tdt sexualidad
eso es hilera que cuadra
definitivamente la vida ha bendecido al
inah trial una mujer que ha logrado
siempre vivir su pasión y cuál es esa
pasión ayudar y es que nunca me canso de
decirle a mis hijos
que esté a pasión en la vida
porque si logras hacer tu vida y
trabajar en tu vida con tu pasión
los sacrificios nunca van a ser
sacrificios para hacer un motivo más
para que sigas haciendo lo que más te
gusta hacer
y es que la vida nos da un regalo enorme
a nosotras las mujeres pero grandísimos
es el regalo de la procreación y con ese
regalo va de la mano el rol de las
cuidadoras y con ese regalo del don del
rol de cuidadoras va de la mano con el
servicio y si recordamos la prioridad de
la evolución que nos dice darwin en su
teoría de la evolución nos dice que la
evolución se da por la capacidad de
adaptarnos a los cambios y no por la
fuerza
y resulta que ese regalo que nos dieron
con el rol de cuidadoras hizo que fuera
el servicio y evolucionando cada vez más
en nosotras de manera innata para
volverlo nuestra fortaleza como mujeres
y es por eso que podemos decir que hoy
ese servicio nos llevó a que nosotras
las mujeres lideremos en nuestro hogar
pero porque lideramos en el hogar porque
de verdad sinceramente queremos lo mejor
para nuestros hijos para nuestra familia
y ese sentir innato de servir y de
querer lo mejor nos lleva a que hacer
líderes por el ejemplo en nuestra casa
entonces dirán bueno y por qué línea
triana y médica bueno porque por esa
pasión que ese deseo innato de servir de
vocación de servicios como le dicen
algunos padres coge medicina pero si
ponemos a preguntarnos entonces el por
qué
cirugía plástica y cirugía plástica se
supone que es una especialidad que la
tildan como banal de light cierto como
es superficial pero creo que el que
piense eso es porque de verdad no conoce
la historia del cirujano plástico o de
nuestra realidad como tal
como nacimos nosotros después de las
guerras mundiales resulta que hay había
tecnología médica para salvar los
soldados que caían heridos en la guerra
entonces los médicos que hacíamos
salvamos vidas cierto las vidas de sus
soldados
pero resulta que había
un grupo de médicos que tenía una
sensibilidad especial que de verdad se
sintieron digámoslo a sentadas sentados
al lado de esos pacientes albert a
escuchar y escuchaban cosas como estas
doctor estoy vivo pero no quiero vivir
pero como así si lo saltamos los autores
que mi idea no tiene sentido así
entonces es el grupo de médicos con una
sensibilidad especial y con esa escucha
generosa entendió que lo más importante
no era salvar la vida
lo más importante era devolverle la
calidad de vida a esa persona y ahí
naciendo nosotros los cirujanos
plásticos de los que venimos haciendo
desde hace mucho tiempo
y no me canso de repetir que la vida
definitivamente me apremia
y porque me ha premiado
porque desde que empecé mi vida
profesional mi vida como cirujana
plástica / una práctica muy muy ocupada
de cirugía plástica estética que mi
padre
y con ese sentir innato de servicio de
escuchar a los pacientes
me di cuenta que muchos buscaban la
cirugía plástica de pronto por cosas
cerradas
por cosas que definitivamente no
podíamos resolver con cirugía plástica
muchas veces creen que cirugía plástica
es magia
y no eso no es verdad entonces así como
muchas veces contaban historias
maravillosas de cómo había hecho la
cirugía plástica para de verdad poder a
esas personas o cambiar en la vida que
muchas veces se dan con esa escucha
generosa que siempre me nace del corazón
descubrí que esa cirugía plástica
estética a muchos pacientes las dejaba
más vacías
y recordando esa escucha generosa y tal
vez porque era mujer y tenía tiempo
estaba empezando entonces logré que
muchas veces pacientes abrirán su
corazón y cuando harían el corazón me di
cuenta que de verdad muchas se quejaban
de algo en común
y era su inconformidad no satisfacción
sino plenitud de su vida sexual o de su
sexualidad
así que por eso empecé a entrenarme en
2005 2007 en todo lo que era cirugía
plástica vaginal y a investigar a ver lo
que existía lo que no existía cómo
podemos mejorar y con esa verdad ganas
de compartir y ayudar empecé a
compartirlo con mis colegas por todo el
mundo
y así fue como hoy en día soy una
pionera a nivel mundial
cuando hablamos de reconocimiento
vaginal
y de verdad me enorgullece muchísimo ver
como en estos últimos 10 años la cirugía
plástica vaginal ha ido en un aumento
increíble
año tras año tras año
hasta ver hoy en día cómo ha aumentado
en un 56% los procedimientos de
reconocimiento vaginal a nivel mundial y
si los comparamos con el resto de los
procedimientos de cirugía plástica
estética estos solos han aumentado un 8%
entonces definitivamente todo esto que
digamos lo que nació por ese sentir de
ayudar vemos que de verdad tiene frutos
de verdad estamos ayudando a muchos
pacientes que lo necesitaban
y si hablamos nuevamente de la mujer hoy
en día ocupamos el 40 por ciento del
mercado laboral está en nuestras manos y
curiosamente nosotras supone que somos
el sexo débil o también estamos
empezando a liderar en los aspectos
laborales ya no somos sólo las líderes
del hogar hoy en día cada vez más
ganamos a nivel de liderazgo en las
empresas y en nuestro trabajo
y por qué será esto porque seguimos
haciendo cuando estamos en el trabajo lo
que mejor sabemos hacer y que es servir
y sintiendo nuestros pares nos eligen
como su líder porque el verdadero líder
liderado por el ejemplo y no por la
fuerza y éstas somos nosotras las
mujeres y es así como fui nombrada la
primera mujer por mis colegas votada la
primera mujer presidente de la
asociación colombiana de cirugía
plástica estética reconstructiva y hoy
en día intento también el título como
primera mujer electa de la presidencia
de la asociación colombiana de
sociedades científicas
[Aplausos]
y es curioso pues como siendo
supuestamente la mujer es el sexo débil'
nos hizo evolucionar hacia un liderazgo
por el ejemplo en cambio los hombres en
su rol del sexo fuerte continuaron
liderando por la fuerza
hoy en día podemos decir pues que las
mujeres venimos de hace mucho rato
liderando en el hogar
y podemos decir también hoy que estamos
liderando en este trabajo cierto
por lo menos eso es lo que estamos
diciendo
pero será verdad
tenemos igualdad
ostentamos equidad entre hombres y
mujeres cómo nos sentimos en esta
sociedad que vivimos
será verdad que tenemos las mismas
oportunidades siendo hombres que siendo
mujeres
y será que cuando hablamos de sexo estas
oportunidades son las mismas ustedes qué
opinan
definitivamente como mujer
como esposa como mamá como hija como
hermana como médica como cirujana
plástica promuevo con pasión el
empoderada mujer en todos los aspectos
de su vida
y es que tenemos que dejar a un lado el
cuento de que la vagina es un tabú
eso tiene que borrarse de la mente
porque definitivamente las mujeres
tenemos que empoderarnos también de
nuestra sexualidad
para que de verdad podamos ser libres
entonces hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes tres pasos
para que seamos libres
y cuáles son estos pasos primer paso
tenemos que reconocer que no somos la
mujer maravilla'
porque porque resulta que como nos
venden el cuento de que tenemos ese don
innato del servicio lo cual es cierto
entonces no nos creemos que como tenemos
ese don innato del servicio tenemos que
servir a todo el mundo y sirviendo al
todo el mundo que decir que nos tenemos
que cargar de todo lo que lo que más
podamos entonces queremos que vivir en
un constante multi tasking si quien es
el constante multi tasking será que
estamos teniendo equidad
será que estamos teniendo igualdad
entonces por favor nunca nos dejemos
echarnos el cuento que somos la mujer
maravilla y nunca nos dejemos cargar
es muy importante defender nosotras
mismas que no nos debemos cargar si
nosotros somos líderes innatas entonces
vamos a usar esos dones de liderazgo y
que tenemos que hacer tenemos que
emplear a todos nuestros aliados al
marido a la mamá a la suegra a la
hermana a la prima a la vecina si a las
amigas a todo el que podamos a los
colegas del trabajo a los empleados a
todo el mundo y lo más importante es que
siempre conciliamos quién va a ser que
para de esa manera repito nunca dejarnos
sobrecargar
segundo paso cuál va a ser debemos
enseñar que no existen roles
predeterminados y esto lo tenemos que
fomentar desde nuestra familia desde
nuestros hijos porque recuerden nosotros
somos líderes y natos en el lugar
entonces quien mejor que nosotras
tenemos una responsabilidad que de
verdad esos hijos crezcan sin roles este
cuento de los roles se tiene que acabar
quien haga la tarea o la acción la va a
ser porque de verdad le apasiona hacerla
o porque de verdad mejor en hacerla pero
no porque el mujer o porque es hombre
eso definitivamente lo tenemos que
acabar y recuerden que nosotros somos
las mejores embajadoras para lograrlo
y tercer paso cuál va a ser vivir la
vida con pasión y cómo vamos a lograr
vivir nuestra vida con pasión
tenemos que siempre luchar por la
equidad por la igualdad recuerden no nos
sobre carguemos porque esa es la única
manera de que podamos de verdad
sentirnos libres si no nos dejamos
sobrecargar vamos a poder vivir nuestra
vida con pasión y de verdad ser libres y
si somos libres como vamos a hacer si
somos libres haciendo lo que en verdad
nos gusta vamos a hacer felices
así que mujeres nosotros tenemos que ser
las embajadoras desde nuestro hogar
desde nuestro trabajo y en todos los
aspectos de nuestra vida de promover
siempre que tenemos que vivir nuestra
vida con pasión
y quiero
ya casi por terminar leer esta frase con
ustedes de nado mi bolso porque es que
la vagina controlar la confianza
femenina
la creatividad y el sentido de
trascendencia así que no te avergüences
no te avergüences nunca de tu vagina no
te avergüences este sentido porque es
que ese sentir es un regalo grandísimo
que nos han dado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]